[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando mi hanno proposto di fare un ted
talk ho pensato ma io ma io sono una
ricercatrice in farmacologia
io lavoro in ospedale e lavoro in
università e fare la farmacologa clinica
in ospedale
vuol dire occuparsi dell'ottimizzazione
delle terapie vuol dire tentare di
personalizzarle vuol dire far sì che
ciascun paziente possa trarre il maggior
beneficio possibile dalle terapie
preimpostate e fare la farmacologa
clinica in università vuol dire eseguire
gli studenti fare esami fare lezioni
fare ricerca in ambito farmacologico io
ho scelto di farla in ottica di genere
vuol dire insegnare io insegno
farmacologia generale e farmacologia
speciale adoro quel momento in cui tutto
quello che ho messo dentro di me per
anni si traduce semplificandosi nella
mente degli studenti e nei loro punti
allora penserete che nel momento in cui
mi hanno proposto un territorio che ho
detto ma no ma io non ce la faccio
in realtà un po di teatro l'ho fatto
nella mia vita un po di divulgazione
scientifica sarei anche giornalista e
dicono che come scrivo si capisce però
un conto è fare una conferenza di taglio
divulgativo che si comprenda un altro
conto davvero e stare qui imprigionata
in questo cerchio di tessuto rosso
cercare di non uscire in un velo di con
sé anche l'ansia che ho nel tentare di
non uscire perché io in realtà
appartengo a quella categoria di persone
definita nerd e sono anche andate a
cercare la definizione sul vocabolario
online sentite persona giovane
ossessionata da una disciplina di studio
dal fisico poco prestante solitamente
malvestita
a parte l'esser giovane il resto c'è
tutto è un caso oggi ecco diciamo e
quindi ho detto ma noi non ce la faccia
ma poi ho detto ma si sono nerd ci provo
lo faccio lo stesso al massimo qualcuno
del pubblico si innamora di ciò che
faccio della farmacologia di genere
allora per farlo voglio raccontarvi una
storia
tutto è cominciato dal cuore il cuore
delle donne
siamo all'inizio degli anni novanta per
la precisione nel 1991 bernardini il ii
una cardiologa statunitense io me la
sono sempre immaginata come una persona
tosta intelligente forte perspicace
berni affinché fa osserva studia
analizza le persone che quotidianamente
vengono ammessi al suo reparto e si
rende conto che gli uomini e le donne
vengono trattati in modo diverso la
sintomatologia dell'infarto nelle donne
viene riconosciuta più tardivamente
mentre gli uomini subito le donne
vengono ospedalizzate spesso in reparti
sbagliati medicina interna non
cardiologia per quello che è un infarto
ma non si riconosce per essere tale
le donne subiscono minori attenzioni e
minori cure
allora che fa bernardin verrebbe scrive
pubblica un articolo sul new england
journal of medicines una delle riviste
scientifiche più prestigiose a livello
mondiale e lo chiama la sindrome di gli
enti prendendo la storia da un eroina
del premio nobel isaac singer alla
narrativa niente è una ragazza che
finché era vivo il padre un rabbino
poteva studiare diciamo la religione
ebraica ma nel momento in cui il padre
muore lei che fa
si taglia i capelli si veste da uomo è
così fingendosi uomo può continuare a
studiare ciò che vuole studiare il
messaggio di berna viene dunque è sempre
all'inizio degli anni novanta per poter
essere adeguatamente curate bisogna
fingersi uomo
beh ma bernardin questo è un problema
che fonda le radici nel passato perché
galeno nel ii secolo dopo cristo galeno
medico e filosofo diceva che le donne
sono caratterizzate da organi genitali
introversi e malamente sviluppati ed eli
chiaramente il problema dell'infertilità
perché vesalio a metà del 1500
diceva che bastava semplicemente
studiare il corpo maschile quale forma
neutra universale poi applicare tutto il
resto alle donne per differenza perché
il primo ospedale il mauriziano è stato
fondato a torino a metà del 1500
ma quanto tempo pensate ci sia voluto
per realizzare un reparto per le donne
trecento anni a metà del 1800
allora bernardin cosa vuoi dire al
pubblico
bernabe indice che un corpo che non
esiste è un corpo che non ha diritti che
un cuore che non viene studiato e un
cuore che non viene curato il mio amico
giurista in realtà mi spiega da tempo
che spesso anche chi esiste può non
avere diritti ma questo magari lo
teniamo per un'altra ted conference più
avanti forse dovresti signori e dal 1946
che l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ci descrive la salute come uno
stato di completo benessere fisico e
psicologico e non come la semplice
assenza di malattia
lo dice la nostra costituzione
nell'articolo 32 la salute una di è uno
dei pochi diritti inalienabili
di ogni uomo e di ogni donna lo dice la
dichiarazione dei diritti universali con
l'articolo 25
e allora noi universitari accademici noi
clinici cosa possiamo fare
a norma di legge possiamo tentare di
costruire una medicina che sia il più
inclusiva possibile una medicina di
genere e quindi anche una farmacologia
di genere forse non lo sapete ma la
maggior parte dei farmaci ad oggi in
commercio è stata testata tramite studi
di sperimentazione preclinica soltanto
su animali maschi e attraverso studi di
sperimentazione clinica arruolando
soltanto uomini
l'aspirina un farmaco che prendiamo
quotidianamente tutti e tutte l'aspirina
è stata immessa in commercio dopo uno
studio di sperimentazione clinica che è
durato vent'anni negli anni 80 e che ha
arruolato più di 20 mila persone solo
uomini la talidomide un farmaco un
potentissimo antiemetico che è stato
somministrato alle donne in gravidanza a
cavallo degli anni cinquanta in realtà
era anche un potentissimo inibitore
dell'angiogenesi cioè bloccava lo
sviluppo dei vasi sanguigni ma mai è
stato testato prima di essere messo in
commercio sulle donne in gravidanza
e allora nell'era pre ecografica molte
donne hanno abortito spontaneamente
molti bambini non sono nati molti sono
nati con braccia e gambe atrofizzate
sono i focomelici che oggi hanno 65 70
anni nessuna tara genetica
nessuna sindrome particolare nessuna
malattia assenza di sperimentazione
preclinica e clinica del farmaco e tutto
questo perché perché le donne sono un
caos perché le donne hanno tantissimi
fattori confondenti perché le donne
hanno questo pessimo vizio magari di
volere una gravidanza
le donne allattano le donne vanno in
menopausa
le donne assumono contraccezione
ormonale in ognuna di noi ci sono almeno
tre fasi produttive differenti della
vita
le bambine le donne che hanno il ciclo
nel periodo fertile la menopausa e siamo
tutte molto diverse a livello intra
individuale l'uomo è caratterizzato da
settant'anni di banalità ormonale
e quindi è un semplicissimo campione di
studio nel senso che ci dà dei risultati
semplici da interpretare ma io credo che
ciò che è complesso come la donna e
mentre parlo delle donne penso alla
popolazione transgender per le quali non
ci sono studi ad hoc
ciò che il complesso meriti maggiormente
attenzione e interesse di studio il
concetto di uguaglianza
lasciamolo ad altri campi lasciamolo al
campo economico remunerativo se uomo e
donna fanno lo stesso lavoro allora
dobbiamo pensare che guadagnano
assolutamente lo stesso compenso
all'ambito linguistico non diciamo per
aria non diciamo dottore ma la parità
linguistica di genere deve entrare
nell'educazione scolare dei nostri figli
da oggi in ambito clinico terapeutico io
voglio parlare di equita la uguaglianza
e dare a tutti le stesse cose
l'equità e dare a tutti le stesse
possibilità perché se partiamo da
situazioni personali differenti e chiaro
che se tutti abbiamo le stesse cose non
arriviamo o meglio ancora di giustizia
sociale la giustizia sociale poli è
davanti agli occhi di noi gli ostacoli e
ci darsi le stesse cose che possiamo
dunque perseguire con le stesse
possibilità
e allora cosa voglio fare continuare a
lavorare come sto facendo in università
in ospedale il sistema sanitario
nazionale non mi richiede di refertare
in modo diverso per uomo e per donna ma
di differenze nel mio lavoro né noto né
noto tantissime allora voglio continuare
a pubblicare con il mio gruppo di lavoro
ea rivedere i dati in ottica di genere
separando le popolazioni ma non con
intento discriminatorio
le differenze vanno sottolineate
studiate apprezzate
vorrei creare un centro di farmacologia
clinica di genere
all'interno del quale ciascun paziente
possa entrare portando le proprie
variabili individuali ed essere studiato
in modo assolutamente e curato in modo
personalizzato e quindi per come sono
fatta
ce lo voglio proprio mettere un punto un
punto alla fine di una frase un punto
alla fine di una storia si chiama
ortografia o per meglio dire coraggio e
questo punto di coraggio per me è un
punto di partenza
grazie